[Music]
new friends
you got me now
[Music]
Coco Austin and her seven-year-old
daughter Chanel know how to put on a
show I like it
the pair who regularly team up to film
Tick Tock videos did their first lip
sync in 2020. hey I have Tick Tock now
you don't yeah no so how do I do it do I
just sing no yeah you remember that time
when the whole world was born
but the family wasn't bored for long
Holy Spirit activate oh no
Holy Spirit activate activate
yeah mom and daughter kept their spirits
bright by busting a move
for their skills go beyond the Dance
Floor all the way to the kitchen
[Music]
with Mom Coco and Dad iced Tea's DNA
it's not exactly surprising that Chanel
is a born Entertainer
um we're not fighting and my door's
unlocked I think someday you're gonna
have a star on the Walk of Fame are you
going to
yeah this one's like a little actress
right a little actress yeah she's not
afraid of the stage definitely she's a
little talented girl right here proving
she's ready for the stage Chanel's used
Tick Tock to show off her acting skills
who's who's Veronica Monica can we not
fight anymore please
um we're not fighting and my door's
unlocked now the people in power are our
children and Chanel's got the power when
it comes to making content starring in
an even editing videos by herself
well look at that he can count Coco
captioned the clip future actor and
director so much passion in this kid I
just get excited over the little things
recently the family celebrated a big
thing when Chanel got her very first
talent agent I wanted to go in the route
of not knowing someone everybody's like
oh you know someone in Hollywood you
know a friend you should you know it's
that's the easy route I really wanted to
go buy the book you know I really wanted
her to audition she auditioned for a
prestigious agency called Zuri and she
got in and yeah we just started we've
been uh you know auditioned for Sesame
Street and all that good stuff so you
never know what might come through yeah
Chanel's auditioning for kids shows but
her dream role is the polar opposite
scream or something like that
what's the other one
she's got a really really crazy scream I
have to say she does this like fake
scream inside the car when Isis driving
all the time and it blows his eardrums
out he's like oh you're gonna do
something with that scream one day girl
yes we love it if Chanel's tick tocks
are any indicator the kids got a bright
future in Hollywood
so come around
[Music]